ça se présente bien je suis ici ça fait
déjà une semaine donc beaucoup le ventre
il faut filage et avec une belle
deuxième place il senti que les gens
mettaient pandev revient donc avec
l'équipe aussi parce qu'on était quand
même trois alignés de la martinique
c'est du christ à chicago et on avait
déjà radio le rituel pour la sélection
donc je pense que ça s'annonce bien
l'état d'esprit pour le départ du tout
une bonne état d'esprit on a un impact
co2 enfin cette année je vois que
illégales sont très mitigés ainsi que
moi donc j'espère que l'on va on va
faire un beau coup sûr cette édition
2010 9 et pourquoi pas ramener le
maillot marine pour moi ça va s'adapter
pour moi pour mes fins de mois donc et
le visionnage du pape au niger en tête
quand tu prends pour moi ça va être un
tour assez assez on va dire juste pour
faire plaisir sur moi et puis pourquoi
pas une victoire d'utah finale déjà
participé à ce tour de bordeaux pas de
reprise commenté la banque
bullard mais là je la vends de problème
à ce contrôle donc pour moi ce sont à
disposition
pour moi c'est aussi plaisir on
mais deux années de formation positif le
velodi tomasini qui était s'était il est
assez satisfaisant pour moi là je suis
de retour en guadeloupe mais je verrai
ce que ce que les gens vont donner avec
les équipiers si tu attends une
confrontation de haut niveau on voit
loupé ça jamais tier 2 bin niveau donc
trois fois ça sent toujours une belle
confrontation dans le chat gagner
comment tu à bord de ce fait tous les
espoirs kodjo bain avant tout aider
l'équipe et puis après un podium une
victoire d'étape pourquoi pas mais
connaissant ça sera à l'aide à l'équipe
en tout cas pour mon premier tour devant
nous donc
déjà t elle de terminer aider les
coéquipiers moi si je préfère au moins
deux podiums aller chercher une victoire
d'étape
oui j'ai déjà entendu c
beaucoup plus élevé que le tremblement
unique donc apprécié s'accrocher au balo
du tour de martinique pense que
l'argumentation vol ben je vais dire que
oui la préparation est bonne donc à
point si pour le résultat sur le toit